salut tout le monde alors cette semaine
une vidéo un peu spécial puisqu'il va
s'agir d'une rétro nostalgique sur une
des époques les plus horribles des jeux
vidéo une époque qui a vu passer un
nombre incroyable de jeux puis c'est
quand on demande aux gens quel est leur
période préférée dans les jeux vidéos
souvent on a des réponses du genre avec
moi j'adorais l'époque des gens de
desbiens rétro
d'autres vous diront mais moi j'adore
les jeux maintenant tout en croit deux
définitions mais il ya un truc que tout
le monde oublie c'est contre ça et ça il
ya quelque chose on n'est pas passé
directement de super mario bros à mario
galaxy il ya eu une époque où les jeux
sont passés de la 2d à la 3d et ça
c'était pas beau à voir
alors évidemment le passage de la 2d à
la 3d s'est fait essentiellement sur
saturne playstation et nintendo 64
il ya des jeux qui ont parfaitement
réussi leur transition il suffit de voir
zelda ocarina of time ou mario avec
l'excellent mario 64 pour qui ça a été
un changement total de gameplay alors
que de l'autre côté sonic le concurrent
de toujours de mario s'est
lamentablement vautré dans son passage à
l'e3 nous faut comprendre que mario et
sonic team tendo et sega c'était presque
comme appartenir à un parti politique à
l'époque c'était sangoku contre végéta
c'était le rouge contre le bleu même les
consoles étaient différentes
toute la gamme nintendo était blanche
alors que la gamme sega était noir et ça
a donné lieu à des débats beaucoup dans
les communautés pour savoir lequel des
deux était le mieux pour moi le choix
par contre été vite fait je veux dire
d'un côté un plombier italien moustachu
se transforme en laveur et de
l'autre les retours bleus pour à la
vitesse de la lumière et qui se
transforme en super guerrier
mais bon pour sonic il aurait mieux valu
que ne passe jamais la 3d parce que ce
hérisson a participé à tellement de
n'avait que sa carrière est un véritable
potager et ça m'a fait mal de dire ça
parce que je suis un fan de sonic
allez on va commencer par sonic 3d blast
sur megadrive
vallat
[Musique]
là je dis aime il ya des sites qui
trompe pas quand même quand tu vois
qu'on est passé 2 à ça et je parle pas
de l'intro regarder le pauvre indien le
tigre os car il peut encore y est ça
c'est les premiers signes de la
dégénérescence neuronale de sonic l'epa
sont sur l'incroyable scénario qui
consiste à récupérer les causes symbole
pour la 37e fois donc vous devez
chercher tous les ennemis pour libérer
les petits oiseaux dans ce monde en 3d
isométrique
il vous faudra donc du doigté de la
réflexion de la patience afin de trouver
les ennemis cachés un peu partout dans
les différents niveaux de la réflexion
et de la patience
en jouant à sonic commayras sérieux je
dis merde quoi sonic c'est tout le
contraire de la patience c'est la
vitesse c'est l'action c'est
l'improvisation ce jeu va totalement à
l'encontre même de l'esprit de la série
c'est comme si on te demandait d'avoir
des des réflexes pour jouer à simcity
quoi je veux dire mais j'ai pas envie de
perdre une heure chercher des ennemis
sonic c'est pas censé être un jeu
d'exploration et dans le même genre on
avait sonic labyrinthe dire quand on
pense à sonic la plupart des gens
pensent à la vitesse nous et là regardez
ce n'est courrier attention ça va vite
sérieusement sonné qui court vite
ça me semble aussi basique comme idée
que mario qui saute mais non mais même
ça il faut croire que c'est trop
compliqué pour les développeurs dans des
tentatives désespérées de contrer mario
kart on a eu aussi droit à des jeux de
courses comme sonic r sur saturne
snooker dressing une structure smic r
comme ratée
tu prends mario kart tu retires tout le
fun est à sonic r je vais pas m'étendre
de suis tellement ce jeu est chiant la
maniabilité est juste où il le veut un
simple exemple voilà dix secondes de
gameplay
[Musique]
je vous jure je vous jure que j'essaye
de couler 3 mais c'est un possible je
suis bourré quoi mais c'est fou que je
n'ai j'arrive pas à faire 30 mètres sans
manger un mur et ce qui est terrible
c'est que sonic encore c'est pas le pire
je sais pas si c'est moi mais taille
c'est une savonnette lui même et ses
dérapages de fou une éruption de
kilomètres là je parlerai même pas du
nombre de circuits qui s'élève au nombre
incroyable de 5 et par contre il ya un
truc dans ce jeu que je ne comprends pas
soyons sérieux au 10e rang c'est quoi ce
délire avec la musique
sérieusement ça me fait penser à sonic
savoure ont directement d'une boîte de
nuit de la côte d'azur
et sonic au fil de ces jeux continuera
ainsi sa chute inexorable hanche et dans
les jeux plus mauvais les uns que les
autres
transformation en loup garou
multiplication d'histoires et de
personnages inutiles jeu totalement
buggé au fond du trou sonic en était
même réduits à se prostituer auprès de
mario pour qu'ils le laissent apparaître
dans ces jeux
triste fin d'un héros solitaire qui
jamais et oui mais pourtant
n'oubliez pas ce que dit aragorn pour
faire non pas ça ça il y a toujours de
l'espoir
et oui parce que sonic est de retour en
2d avec son niqab
comme si ces 16 dernières années depuis
sonic 3 n'avait pas existé et moi en
tout cas en tant que fan de sonic
j'espère que ça va marquer un nouveau
départ d'ailleurs c'est pas le seul jeu
à faire autour ressources en ce moment
c'est la grande mode de revenir à la 2d
comme pour castagner rebirth des 49ers
pour dit maltais quelques exemples de
jeux comme une adaptation misérables qui
ont bien failli complètement tué leur
licence la nintendo 64 s'était fait une
spécialité de faire des adaptations
prenait de merde
en fait tous les jeux soit 104 avait à
peu près un problème et c'est à dire une
maniabilité complètement naze et surtout
une caméra épouvantable qui avait
tendance à toujours se coller au mauvais
endroit
on va prendre castlevania 64 alors il ya
des gens qui aiment mémoire sincèrement
j'ai pas aimé du tout le jeu a perdu
tout son côté rapide et nerveux pour se
transformer et espèce de de jeu
d'exploration sans saveur niveau sonore
on est passé de ça
au moins comme ça je me ferai pas de
musique et on va dire un détail fatigant
c'est que vous regagnez pas directement
votre énergie comme des anciens jeux en
fait que vous ramassez les trucs vous
êtes obligé de passer par le menu tout
le temps ah bon ça a ses avantages mais
votre et franchement je trouve que ça
casse le rythme j'en fait délirer ça
dans le jeu vous imaginez en plein
combat contre les zombies en train de
sortir une cuisse de poulet 2 secondes
quand le passage de la vue classique de
côté en 2d à la vue 3d de doha est une
catastrophe apprécier les distances
c'est vraiment devenu vraiment vraiment
dur que ce soit au fouet pour toucher
les ennemis ou pour les sauts je dire
notamment sur ce passage là c'est
vraiment c'est particulièrement choquant
car tous ceux qui ont une manette de 64
jours dans les mains là doivent le
comprendre
allez appui fort ça savais-tu dracula et
s'est même pas foutu d'apprendre à nager
connard bon là je parle de linden nous
sommes calmes et la playstation aussi a
eu ses murs les quizz l'a dominé dans
quel but il s'agit mortel combat spécial
forces
oui oui mortal kombat et je parle bien
de ça
paul biya oui suite à noter à ses vrais
wyatt en voilà oui mais voilà c'est vrai
que quand tu laisses le logo en fait ça
devient vachement plus clair
heureusement que ce truc est là pour te
rappeler à quoi tu joues donc sinon tu
aurais tendance à vite oublier
en gros dans ce jeu on commente jack ce
personnage tellement charismatique que
je m'en souviens plus je veux dire qu'il
t'a voulant faire du fric sur la licence
de mortal kombat pourquoi pas prendre un
mec plus connus comme redouane sub zero
ou scorpion sinon je ne résiste pas à
l'envié de vous montrer la magnifique
intro du jeu
[Musique]
non mais là c'est mortal kombat austin
powers édition en fait un jeudi à l'ats
quand tu passes de ça à ça et je veux
dire après une intro comme ça tu
t'attends presque approuve un joint dans
la boîte pour le jeu donc voix il s'agit
d'un beat them all classique avec le
délire habituel de passer son temps
cherché des interrupteurs pour avancer
les combats sont passionnants ou et les
bosses ça ressemble à tout sauf à du
mortal kombat évidemment je voudrais
préciser qu'il n'ya pas de fatalité à
genève faut pas déconner non plus et là
maintenant je vais montrer le jeu le
plus mauvais de toute cette génération
en 3d ce jeu a été tellement un échec
total que son héros a complètement
disparu depuis
alors il me dit est un héros qui a
commencé sur megadrive et sur super nes
en 1993 wifi quelques jeux il a
d'ailleurs même eu droit à des suites en
1994 puis en 95 sur pc les jeux étaient
plutôt pas mal dynamique rapide univers
assez déjanté 9 600 voulais partir pour
avoir un bel avenir
quand ce terrible jour arriva
si 3d est aussi étrange que cela puisse
vous paraître d'ailleurs je vous
conseille d'y jouer pour rigoler un bon
coup et aussi pour bien comprendre à
quel point ce jeu est complètement foiré
déjà rien que ça écoutez la musique
d'intro
regardez la tête de boeuf zee
moi je trouve cette ambiance mais
carrément malsaine je veux dire c'est
censé refléter un personnage marrant
vous trouvé marrant vous conduire une
fusion entre star fox et le joker donc
le jeu on se promène dans un monde
horrible avec des bleus ratent arracher
la rétine ne sais pas où aller
et encore on décore ils apparaissent ou
disparaissent sans aucune raison qu'on
fait même plus la différence entre les
vrais texture si on peut appeler ça des
textures et les deux graphiques
d'ailleurs au bout d'un moment de jouer
à ce jeu avec toutes ses couleurs fluo
flashy qui t'agresse le cerveau vraiment
à l'évocation de jouer sous l'effet de
substances
[Musique]
d'ailleurs en fait je pense sérieusement
que les développeurs codé aussi leur jeu
sous lsd s'expliquerait le fait que les
textures sont recyclés à absolument tous
les niveaux avec le même vieux damier au
sol ça expliquerait aussi le fait que
les ennemis soit exactement les mêmes
tout le temps à tous les nouvelles avec
la même attaque de merde elle seulement
la couleur qui change
de feignant d'être le plus foiré
dans ce jeu c'est la maniabilité je veux
dire c'est pas possible de faire plus
mauvais nous essayons de faire exprès
entre benzi qui met des heures d qui
veut se tourner et la caméra qui
s'envole dès que tu sois d'histoire de
pleuvoir ce cas devant toi ça devient
vite ingérable
d'ailleurs les sauts sont tellement mal
foutu que deux fois sur trois quand tu
vis d'un ennemi tu atterris à côté
comment quand il me tue ça ils ont pas
brown a par contre niveau cinématiques
quand tu meurs et là ils se sont fait
plaisir un culte aum tu meurs tu te
noies sigrist élégante tutelle brice
france - galles et il y en a pour tous
les goûts
la dernière est quand même plus réaliste
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'ils racontent sérieux tous
les dix mètres quand tu ramasses un truc
de musique lui hurle dessus des trucs
incompréhensibles
sincèrement les portages et aucune
difficulté avec l'anglais mais là je
comprend pas un mot de ce qu'il dit quoi
tais toi tais toi je plaisante à voir
amy est insupportable juteux ferme-là
tout de suite non mais personne ne te
comprendre toute façon alors arrête de
parler voire mais tu étais
vraiment mûr 2d quand tu fermes est ta
grande gueule si vous imaginez c'est
comme si marion a compté samedi jetons
pour amasser un truc ça me rend fou et
si en plus tu cumules la voix de boeuf
vie avec salade de fruits de mer de là
que font les canards pendant les
dix-huit niveaux mettant le
cocktail parfait pour tout appel à la
mi-temps du siècle en fait j'attends que
la musique se gravent dans la tête des
gens qui vont regarder la vidéo
que dire de notre bombe il ya aussi un
mode deux joueurs dans ce jeu enfin
encore faut-il avoir un côté assez con
pour réveiller jouer sinon ben si votre
copé ne veut pas y jouer à me le dit 3d
vous pouvez aussi lui proposer de
regarder un épisode du dessin animé de
même s'ils pensent que oui ça existe et
c'est insupportable
ou alors vous pouvez aussi lui proposer
lui tire une balle dans la tête
très franchement ça sera plus rapide et
ça sera moins cruel bon de toute façon
j'ai aucune envie d'y jouer à deux et
j'ai personnes sous la main pour le
faire alors moralité il vaut mieux un
bon jeu en 2d comme mauvais jeux en 3d
allez
[Musique]
jury
attention tenez vous bien
[Musique]